things
I don't know if we can hear you
yes can you hear me now yeah it's
perfect yeah
okay uh so uh thanks everyone for being
here and I'm sorry I couldn't be there
in person I hope that I'd still be able
to hear any questions you have so please
feel free to interrupt and ask questions
at any point
um this talk is going to be about
certified deleting Secrets uh it's based
on a bunch of recent Works
um I'll mostly focus on this work on
cryptography with certified deletion
which is joined with James bartosec I
will also say a little bit about uh
follow-up Works where uh techniques in
here were extended and uh uh to to
obtain a variety of other Primitives
with certified deletion including
obfuscation uh methods to Outsource
computation uh this is a joint work with
James bartosec sanjum Garg uh both at UC
Berkeley ripple goel at NTT research uh
Julio Manuel Volta at Max blank uh
Justin raises at CMU and Bhaskar Roberts
at UC Berkeley
um I will also talk about time
permitting talk about how to make
deletion publicly verifiable uh again
joint work with James bartosec and with
Alex parambo and finally uh I will just
mention some results on weakening the
assumptions that we need to do publicly
verifiabilitation uh this is joined with
James bartosec Julio malabolta Alex
paramba and Michael Walter
um
okay so
um let me just Dive Right In and try to
explain what it means to realize this
delete button or enable encryption and a
variety of other Primitives with
certified deletion
um for the definition I'm going to start
uh right away with uh you know defining
it
um and to Define encryption with
certified deletion let's take the
example of a public key encryption
scheme
um
but again this is just an example the
style of definition will extend to many
Advanced cryptographic Primitives I
won't necessarily cover all definitions
but it'll be obvious how to extend it
um so in an encryption scheme that
satisfies certified deletion the
encryption and decryption algorithms are
as usual
um we will only consider encrypting bits
again this extends to Strings without
any complications
the main difference from you know
standard public key encryption schemes
is that the encryption algorithm is also
going to Output a verification key
um and also that the ciphertexts will be
Quantum in fact ciphertext will have a
Quantum component and a classical
component so I will just denote the
quantum component with the cat around it
and the classical component you know
it's standard
um the decryption algorithm is again as
huge huge will decrypt the ciphertext to
give a plain text uh well this is a bit
so let's just say bits
um
and the the additional algorithms that
we will have uh will be a delete
algorithm that given a ciphertext
outputs a certificate or this is
supposed to be a proof of having deleted
the underlying plain text
and there will be a verification
algorithm that helps uh some verifier
check the certificate or the proof of
deletion given the verification key VK
that was generated at the time of
encryption okay so this is just going to
be the syntax
um again I haven't told you what this
this all means so let me do that now
uh informally security with certified
deletion means that any adversary that
is polynomially bounded and has access
to a ciphertext and then decides to
delete it generating a deletion
certificate new uh satisfies the
following guarantee if the certificate
verifies then its verification implies
that the bit B underlying the ciphertext
has been information theoretically
removed from the adversaries View
Okay so
we've written that down here this
informal guarantee which is you know
just just saying that verification of
the deletion certificate generated by an
adversary implies that they have
information theoretically removed the
bit B from their view whereas previously
prior to generating this deletion
certificate their view actually
information theoretically determined to
be because it actually were carrying a
cipher text a public key Cipher text
encrypting the bitp
oh
so uh the next question is how do we
make such a certified deletion guarantee
formal and uh to do that
um
we Define the following experiment again
this considers an everlasting flavor of
security which says that an adversary
obtains a public key and a ciphertext
generated by a challenger and then
decides to possibly delete it and after
deletion is left over with some State
row and the guarantee that we have is
that as long as this certificate
verifies we can output the state row if
the certificate doesn't verify then we
don't output anything we output bought
and uh the formal security definition
simply states that the trace distance
which is you know Quantum analog or
statistical distance uh between the
experiment where the adversary was
holding an encryption of Zero versus the
holding an encryption of one is
negligible in case
which is the security parameter so all
this says is that the state row after
deletion has become statistically
information theoretically independent of
the Big B that was encrypted at the
beginning of the extent
um hopefully the definition makes sense
I'll pause a second to see if there's
any questions
no questions here awesome okay so having
defined this
um I want to just talk about some um
applications and some constructions of
schemes with certified deletion this is
from this recent work with James
bartosec uh and they're in and in that
work we obtain commitments satisfying
this a strong type of certified deletion
um
we also obtained revocable time block
encryption attribute based encryption
witness encryption and fully homomorphic
encryption satisfying certified deletion
here the guarantee is that it's an
encryption scheme that satisfies the you
know the standard fully homomorphic
properties but then also allows the
server to delete certifiably delete the
underlying
um uh secrets
thank you
and finally in the same work we
introduced something called Everlasting
we introduce a primitive called
Everlasting security transfer uh this is
in context of two-party and multi-party
computation
um so you all must be familiar with uh
with constructions and uh the concept of
statistically secure uh two-party
computation where it's often possible to
achieve statistical security against at
least one of the players in a two-party
protocol
um in any classical protocol who the
protocol is going to be statistically
secure against is a priority fixed and
cannot be changed once the protocol
begins because we've already started to
computationally leak information to the
other party but the fact that Quantum
encodings can be used to certify the
delete information
um lets us build protocols where
um at the time of running the protocol
one perhaps had security against
unbounded Alice unbounded Bob but then
dynamically in the in between the
protocol they decide well we actually
wanted security against unbounded Bob
and bounded Alice and they can in fact
transfer unbounded security from one
player to the other
um I won't get into how this is
constructed
um necessarily so um
maybe if we have time I'd be happy to
say a little bit about it uh but it
turns out that these same principles uh
help achieve these types of guarantees
also into party computation
um
now let me mention
um some prior work in the area uh this
idea of revoking information uh was
explored by unru in the context of time
block puzzles he built something called
revocable time block puzzles which can
be thought of as a Time Block Puzzle
where an adversary holding a Time locked
encoding can certifiably delete uh this
the underlying encoded message by
generating a Quantum certificate of
deletion
um the concept of certified deletion uh
specifically also with classical
certificates was introduced by broadband
and Islam who also introduced this
terminology
certified deletion and
um they built one-time pads satisfying
the certified deletion uh guarantee uh
so these are information theoretic
encodings
um we're all familiar with one-time bats
where the guarantee is that once
deletion occurs even if the one-time pad
key is leaked after that point and
adversely cannot recover an encoded
Secret
um
there's uh there was also uh some other
some exciting follow-up work uh to this
uh work of broadband and Islam uh first
by Hiroki hiroka morimay nishimaki and
yamakawa who built public key and
attribute based encryption schemes
assuming non-committing encryption uh
the secure the flavor of security that
they obtain is a leakage style uh
security definition as opposed to the
information theoretic style security
that I just discussed
um and
also the non-committing techniques
inherent to some of these works are
inherently limited and uh not powerful
enough or appears that they're not
powerful enough uh to obtain uh
Primitives like fully homomorphic
encryption
um so those were some of the uh
drawbacks of some of these books
um
another exciting work on building
certified Everlasting zero knowledge for
qma which is a zero knowledge protocol
where
um which satisfies statistical soundness
at the time of running the proof but
also statistical
statistical zero knowledge after
deletion
so this is a guarantee where a verifier
can optionally delete any computational
leakage they've obtained about the
witness and then it becomes
statistically zero knowledge against the
verifier and we all know that
statistical soundness and statistical
zero knowledge for NP or qma is in
general
um
we believe this is impossible uh to
achieve uh and and yet uh by introducing
this flavor of deletion it becomes
possible
so I won't say a lot more about that let
me just also mention two works that were
concurrent with the work that I'm going
to be talking about the first is by
paramba who built proofs of deletion for
learning with errors and uh essentially
obtained fully homomorphic encryption
with certified deletion under a strong
conjecture
um I hope to be able to tell you a
little bit more about
um this conjecture and how it's proved
in the later part of this talk
um and so in in one of the works that
I'll talk about we managed to prove this
conjecture and obtain fhe with certified
deletion from the learning with errors
problem
um and finally there was this work of
hiroka marimai nishimaki and yamakawa
who built variants of functional
encryption with Quantum certificates
um and and in an update to their paper
they obtained a lot
um many other interesting results on
building functional encryption schemes
uh with revocation for ciphertext and
secret Keys again I won't be getting
into all the details of these Works um
but I do just want to mention but
there's a lot of interest and excitement
in the area
okay so with that uh done let me move on
to why does Quantum information help us
realize this uh possible delete button
and in what situations can we hope to
realize it
um so before I begin let me just spend a
few minutes a couple of minutes on
background
um
let me just pause for a second again and
see if there's any questions
I'm sorry yeah
um
all right so uh let me start with some
yeah basic background uh in this talk
we'll mostly be using uh bb84 or vice
nurse AIDS these are uh the four states
get zero get one get plus and get minus
uh zero and one are the computational
basis States plus and get minus are
called the hadamard-based states plus is
nothing but
um
a superposition of 0 and 1 with a
positive phase in between them and minus
is a superposition a uniform
superposition of zero and one with a
negative phase between them
um these are also called conjugate
encodings
um for reasons that will become clear in
a few seconds
um and I just want to First mention that
there is a way to there is a notational
um just for notational convenience we
can denote all these states but with get
x sub Theta where Theta denotes the
basis so computational or hadamard and X
denotes the value in that basis so if
theta equals zero then this is the state
get X which gets 0 or get one and if
theta equals one then this is the state
get 0 plus minus 1 raised to the X get 1
divided by root 2. so this is
essentially the plus State or the minus
state
um
okay
so let's move on now it turns out that
if we perform what is called a
computational basis measurement so think
of uh think of this as passing a photon
that is uh polarized in some direction
through a filter that checks whether the
photon is horizontal or vertical
um
uh so this this type of computational
basis measurement when applied to cat0
uh yields outcome zero and when applied
to the state get one is outcome one
which essentially means that it helps
perfectly discriminate between the
states get zero and get one
and it turns out that if you applied a
computational basis measurement to a
hazamard basis State instead which is
okay plus or kit minus State then what
you get in both cases is a uniformly
random bit that is independent of the
state that you started out measuring
okay so a computational basis
measurement of a hadamard-based state
perfectly erases information post
measurement perfectly erases information
about the state that one had started out
with
similarly a hagamard basis measurement
will perfectly distinguish between two
hadamard-based states uh always tell you
whether you started with a get Plus or
get minus of course I'm assuming that
these are all ideally physically
realizable which may not be true in
practice but for the purposes of theory
we can assume this and uh also if you
did if you performed a hadamard basis
measurement on a computational basis
State then you're going to lose
information after measurement you will
lose information about whether the state
was a zero or a One to begin
okay so now with all that background out
of the way
um and before going all the way to
building encryption schemes with
deletion properties let's try to build a
really simple primitive uh called a
revocable secret sharing scheme so this
is just like you know secret sharing two
out of two secret sharing that we all
know and love
um the idea is that there's a dealer
Alice who has a secret B and she wants
to be able to generate two shares of it
uh hand over these shares to Bob and
Charlie
such that if Bob and Charlie get
together then they will be able to
reconstruct the bit B but each
individual share perfectly hides the bit
B from the individual owner's view so if
Bob and Charlie are isolated then each
of them has no clue what the bit B is
um so that's the usual secret sharing
guarantee so far now you may notice that
I put KET around one of these shares so
I want one of them to be Quantum and the
reason for that is that I'd like to have
another uh interesting property or I'd
like to have the secret sharing scheme
satisfy another interesting property
which is revocation
the revocation property simply says that
Alice should be able to ask one of these
parties let's say Bob who's holding the
quantum share to delete the share and as
a result of deletion Bob should generate
a certificate or a proof for Alice that
they deleted their share and some
leftover State row
um
and the guarantee is that once deletion
has occurred as long as this proof
verifies
so Alice will check the proof this will
say yes or no if the proof verifies then
at this point the joint view of Bob and
Charlie which is the residual globe of a
few uh sorry the residual view of Bob
combined with the view the share that
Charlie holds
jointly
have become independent of the bit B
so
prior to revocation
share one and share to jointly
determined B uh but once revocation
occurs
um row and share two have jointly become
independent of B now you may wonder that
you know of course if Bob and Charlie
are sitting in the same room they should
be able to use share one and share two
reconstruct B and then apply any delete
algorithm and yes so here it is
extremely important that uh
this delete procedure occurs assuming or
occurs in a setting where Bob and
Charlie are isolated so they can be
entangled but they should not be allowed
to communicate with each other
um
now if you take the example of a simple
exhaust secret sharing scheme for
instance where all the shares are
classical then there is no way to
implement this but it turns out that
with Quantum shares one can in fact
build such a secret sharing scheme that
allows revocation
um
the way one would build it again it just
simply uses those four bb84 states
um
and the idea is Alice will sample two
strings X Theta and then generate k x
sub Theta
um which is nothing but a bunch of bb84
red codings
um so the ith qubit in catex sub Theta
is nothing but the ith bit of X in basis
corresponding to the either bit of theta
okay so these are just a bunch of think
of them as polarized photons that Alice
is sending over to Bob
um
and in addition
so that's that's what Bob's share is and
we're going to use this to uh enable
deletion
and Charlie's share will contain an
encoding of the actual bit B that Alice
is trying to secret share
um
with respect to uh the parity of X that
Alice used uh in order to generate Bob's
encoding okay and Alice will also send
to Charlie the basis information Theta
um so hopefully the construction is
clear
um
yeah feel free to ask questions if any
sorry yeah you can continue to cheat on
no question okay
um
all right so how does the revoke
procedure work well to revoke uh Bob's
or to revoke the sharing of B Alice will
simply ask Bob to measure all the bb84
states he received in the hadamard basis
and send all these outcomes to RS now
Alice on her side has uh kept with
herself all the X eyes
or I such that
Theta I is the hadamard basis
and to verify Bob certificate uh Alice
will simply check that for all eye such
that Theta I is indeed the hazamar basis
the IOD weight of X matches the eye bit
of the certificate in other words
at all positions
where
the photons Bob got are actually
polarized in the hadamard basis uh Alice
checks that it is indeed true that the
photon she sent or the the value she
encoded is the same as the one Bob
reports to have measured
um the the really cool property about
these encodings is that given just these
encodings without uh being given any
additional information about bases or
X's they all appear maximally mixed
which means that it's impossible to tell
whether this is polarized in the
horizontal or the vertical basis Etc the
best you can do really is is measure it
in computational or had the word or some
other basis of your choice but you don't
really have any information about what
the polarization was
um and so the reason that that's useful
is that what that means is that Bob
would have actually had to measure
almost all of these photons in the
hadamard basis in order to pass analysis
check and that amounts to deleting apps
so recall that Bob had get x sub Theta
and measuring these photons in the
hardware basis amounts to deleting X
from Bob's View
so
um
in other words Bob's State Post
measurement does not contain information
about X anymore
and which amounts to deleting
B Because all that Charlie has is be
absorbed with the parity of X and if x
is random
um and X is gone then parity of X is
gone so B is gone from their joint view
um even if uh they learn Theta at a
later Point once they collude so
um so hopefully the revocation algorithm
makes sense
um this this is it this is the
construction for secret sharing with
deletion I'm not going to get into the
formal proof of this uh so I I am just
going to talk about
um how uh how this can be used to enable
encryption with certified deletion
um in other words building on the secret
sharing scheme the encrypt algorithm for
an encryption with certified deletion
scheme is just going to send the state
uh cat X Theta together with so recall
this was Bob's share
together with an encryption
of Charlie's chair
and Charlie shell was classical so it's
easy to encrypt this using any classical
encryption scheme
um
so in so how do you construct encryption
with certified deletion well one way to
do it we prove this secure in our paper
is simply have cat x sub Theta as the
quantum part of the ciphertext and
encrypt Theta as well as B Prime where B
Prime is the bit B that was intended to
be encrypted absorbed with the parity of
X this can also be the parity of X just
restricted to positions that are the
compute that correspond to computational
basis States
sorry no Theta is the basis
you know I know it's the base but
good so this is just a public key for
any classical encryption scheme
does that make sense so
Theta and X are the randomness used for
that project indeed yes yes
so by the way can't we give B Prime in
clear yeah
it's a great question
um we struggled to prove semantic
security of the scheme when B Prime is
in the clear
um
it reduced to some combinatorial
construction which was not clear you
know how to prove it so it's open
um to to prove that this is I think yeah
we think it should be secure even if B
Prime is released in the clear but we
don't know how to prove it and it's not
the deletion that's the problem it's
just proving standard semantic security
so so for now because this is what we
can prove we're also going to encrypt B
Prime
all right so thanks for those questions
uh let me move on yeah thank you input
X2 or X sorry so
good so X can only be recovered by
measuring these Quantum States in basis
Theta where Theta is X is given sorry
you give this x you give both uh yeah
okay good you you never give X in the
clear as a string what you give are
quantum Stakes which are encodings of X
and in basis Theta then you encrypt
Theta so today simply recover Theta
measure in basis Theta you get X compute
the parity of X use that to recovery
okay
um so thank you all right so
um this is the encrypt algorithm
um I just told you what the Crypt is uh
so I won't repeat that
um let's talk about deletion
um note that the adversary holds these
Quantum encodings and then a classical
encryption of theta along with B Prime
recall B Prime is nothing but B absorbed
with some parity of x
so now it's possible turns out it's
possible to delete as before
um
simply start with catex Theta and
perform a hagamart basis measurement
so in other words to request the
adversary to delete we ask them to
measure the quantum part entirely you
know all the qubits of the quantum part
in the hadamard basis obtaining a
deletion certificate X prime a residual
State row and you know of course since
this was classical they this this can be
assumed to be a part of their state
always
um
to verify again we will check that are
the hadamard basis positions correct so
for all I where Theta I corresponds to
the hadamard basis let me just say h uh
x i equals x i Prime if this if this is
true then verification accepts and you
know the uh the Challenger accepts that
your adversary did indeed perform
deletion uh if this is false then the
output bought okay
um
so that's how deletion works for the
scheme and
yeah since we've already discussed how
to encrypt decrypt delete and verify I'm
just going to skip the slide and move on
to discussing why is this scheme now uh
certified deletion secure so recall the
definition was
um the Challenger samples of public key
and secret key and a cipher text which
is
um
and encryption with certified deletion
of a bit B
then since the public key and ciphertext
to the adversary who performs deletion
generating a certificate and a residual
state
if their certificate verifies then we
output the state row otherwise we output
bottom and the definition is that the
trace distance between the two
experiments one where the adversary was
obtaining an encryption of zero and the
other where they were obtaining an
encryption of one is negligible
in other words the two experiments are
information theoretically close
is the reason you need to encrypt people
I'm sorry to backtrack but is it that
otherwise you can try to decrypt with
that line Theta and recover partial
so the reason we needed to encrypt uh B
uh or B Prime here I mean it's it's
unclear that actually just given an
encryption of theta whether there's any
way to uh you know recover X and then
recover B
um given B Prime even in the clear
because we think that actually this
should still be hidden computationally
it just turns out to be non-trivial to
prove I'm happy to chat about this
afterwards it's a bit technical so um
thank you thanks actually some new
questions here
um so uh right so for the delete for the
deletion right so uh whoever has like X
um
measures it in the how to Mark basis and
then gives it back to the dealer and the
dealer how does the dealer know what is
X under the how to Mark basis is an X
like some sort of Random register or am
I missing something really basic
um so uh the dealer has kept with them a
copy of X and Theta they were the one
who happens okay okay okay okay that
makes sense
and they actually need to keep this in
order to verify yeah this is not great
so we'll talk about how to remove this
later so and you're using parity
everywhere so partial measurement
doesn't help is that the reason why
um parody appears in a lot of places
um no it's uh no we don't uh it's not
it's not related he's trying to come up
with the simplest scheme there's no
okay
for all those questions
um
any others
okay so if not I'll move on
um
the experiment like I said says if the
certificate verifies we output the state
row and uh security is that the two
experiments or the two states uh
distributions mixed states of the
adversary or one corresponding to where
they received an encryption of zero the
other corresponding to where they
received an encryption of one in cases
where they actually did delete and
deletion did pass the check uh these two
experiments are information
theoretically closed despite the fact
that
um prior to deletion uh these were
information theoretically far and the
encryption actually determines the bit B
so how do we prove something like this
um this is on this slide I've just
written out the game applied to our
particular construction so what the
adversary receives is a public key and
an encryption under the public key of uh
Theta along with v Prime and Cat X Theta
and so on and uh to delete they simply
measure uh the quantum part of the
ciphertext to obtain X Prime and return
it
um
so how do we actually prove that
um this row their leftover State at the
end of this experiment is independent of
the bit B that was being encrypted
um
this turns out to be fairly non-trivial
to prove and to prove it uh we will
start off by deferring dependence of the
experiment on the bitp in particular
imagine that the bit B was only sampled
towards the end of the experiment so in
the beginning we just encrypt random
bits B tilde something else nothing to
do with b and later on if B tilde
happens to be correct and match our bit
B that they experiment you know depends
on then we output the state row
otherwise we output bottom now it turns
out that if betilda is sampled uniformly
at random then there's exactly a
probability half that beta will match
our bit V that the experiment depends on
and so it suffices to analyze this other
experiment where we just came forward
sampling of the bit V2 later and to
prove that in this new experiment
um the trace distance between the
corresponding two experiments one where
B is zero the other where it's one is
negligible
okay
um
The Next Step uh so what this this helps
us do is think about uh this as a
stepping stone to The Next Step where we
simply purify the experiment so now this
is a a bit of a technical term so let me
explain what this means here uh what we
will do is instead of sending to the
adversary these uh maximally mixed uh
bb84 States what we will send to them
instead are halves of epr pairs so epr
pairs are maximally entangled qubits um
gave a very nice talk about entanglement
previously and I'm just going to write
down to remind everyone what epr pairs
are these are qubits that look like zero
zero plus one one by root two uh if you
take one of these qubits the second one
and measure it in the computational
basis and you see a zero then it turns
out that the first qubit has also
collapsed to a gets you if you measure
the second one in the hadamard basis you
see a plus it turns out that the first
one has also collapsed to kept plus so
uh we have this really nice property and
these are going to help us uh just
create mental experiments where we can
see what it is that's been sent to the
adversary
so
the only change from before is that
instead of sending KTX Theta which is
what we were sending before we now
create these halves of epr pairs and
send to the adversary the second half of
every epr pair on a register let's say b
um and keep the first part with
ourselves so a is kept with the
Challenger
and now because the experiment didn't
depend on D until later anyway you can
just send these random halves of epr
pairs along to the adversary and later
on measure the challengers halves of
ecpr pairs in basis corresponding to
Theta to obtain X later on so in other
words in this new experiment we've
deferred sampling of X also to a point
that is much later in the protocol even
after in fact after the adversary has
already claimed to have deleted
okay so
um that's the first change we make
um it turns out again that suffice is to
prove that it's in this experiment the
statistical distance between uh
experiment with a bit is Zero versus the
bit is one is negligible
now in the in the final experiment that
we will consider uh let me just go back
a second and point out that in this in
The Experiment 2 that we were just
talking about uh the adversary actually
does have access to Theta at the time of
generating their deletion certificate so
in this experiment if the adversary was
unbounded at the time of deleting so you
know if the adversary was
unbounded
then they can find Theta
and they can use Theta to measure these
qubits in a proper basis so they know
which one is supposed to be
computational which one is supposed to
be hadamard they'll measure only the
hadamard base ones in the right basis to
find the deletion certificate and since
the bit B is encoded using the
computational basis States they will
keep information about B with themselves
while producing a totally legitimate
looking deletion certificate science
so in this experiment if the adversary
was unbounded then they can in fact
break deletion security and it's
important that they adversely be bounded
and not be able to recover Theta at this
point
um so that means that in the in the next
uh argument we should somehow somewhere
be using the fact that Theta is
computationally hidden from the from the
bounded adversary in order to complete
our proof
the way we do that is we will switch the
encryption of theta to an encryption of
zero now note that this is a
computational switch because this is a
computational switch it turns out that
arguing that experiment 3 where we've
made this computational switch is close
to experiment true uh two is is not
going to work out this is just false in
Experiment three the adversaries view is
computationally closed but statistically
far from their view in experiment two
um so we need a different proof strategy
we need to somehow still be able to make
use of this computational property but
eventually derive an information
theoretically
um so let's see how to do that
um focusing like zooming in on
Experiment three we'll see that
um
it turns out that measuring AI in basis
Theta I
um you know
we we're going to be able to recover our
bit b as usual as before uh the only
main difference is going to be V encrypt
zeros and we can sample Theta a little
bit later
uh the key Insight in our work and I
think I'm going to run out of time very
soon so I'm going to skip over some
details but I'll still tell you the key
Insight which is that we will find an
efficiently checkable predicate on the
adversary State row
uh or essentially an efficiently
checkable uh predicate on these
registers AI that the Challenger has
kept with themselves and this predicate
by virtue of being efficiently checkable
will have to remain the same between uh
or will have to have the same similar
success probability up to negligible
distance between experiment uh two and
Experiment three
so it will turn out that the probability
that this predicate holds in both these
experiments is going to be closed and
that will follow as a result of the
computational hiding of this encryption
scheme
and then we will show that the fact that
this predicate holds in experiment 3
implies that it also holds in experiment
two and the fact that it holds in
experiment two despite the adversary
having an encryption of theta with
themselves will tell us that the bit B
is information theoretically independent
of the adversaries view even in
experiment number two
okay so just to summarize that that uh
really quickly
um we will show that there is some
predicate on the halves of epr pairs AI
that the Challenger holds with
themselves that is true for experiment
two to prove that it is true we will
rely on this mental experiment 3 and
show that it holds an experimental and
because this is an efficient predicate
all efficient properties should be true
with the same probability regardless uh
even in sorry even given computationally
indistinguishable distributions so we'll
use that fact to prove that there's some
predicate on AI that holds in experiment
too and
um use that to derive that the bit B is
statistically hidden from the adversary
now let me just tell you what that
predicate is the predicate simply says
that the registers AI are all close to
hadamard basis registers
foreign
what this means is that whenever the
adversary generates a deletion
certificate that passes verification
then uh the registers AI are closed for
a definition of closeness that I will
not get into uh to all being had them
all basis States all of them not just
the ones that where where Theta was
supposed to be hadamard but they're all
hadamar based States and now this is
great because what happens note that
um what happens is that we get X by
measuring AI in basis Theta I so that
means some of these Heather mod basis
states are going to be measured in the
computational basis to get X I's and
then we will take the parity of these X
I's and use it to mask the bit B
so
we're measuring had more based states in
the computational basis and as I showed
you in those Quantum background slides
if you measure a hadamard-based state in
the computational basis you get a
uniformly random bit and so this gives
essentially a uniformly random mask that
is being used to mask the bit B so
unfortunately I think that's all that I
have time for so I'm going to skip the
rest of this proof and just say a little
bit more about the results
um
you say a little bit more about results
in other dude can I take five more
minutes uh since I I don't know what is
that
next
sorry I couldn't hear it okay okay okay
yes yes so
um all right so let me just uh talk
about some some limitations of this work
that uh we overcome in uh in other works
uh one is that uh these techniques that
I just talked about are inherently
limited to giving CPA style encryption
uh in follow-up work with Bart said
races and Roberts we show that one can
also get CCA secure schemes also
maliciously secure variants of
Delegation the server can be fully
malicious you can Outsource computation
to it and then ask it to information
theoretically delete all your underlying
data we can also get obfuscation and
functional encryption schemes uh with
certified deletion and there's also
other results that do similar
um things sorry
that do similar things uh for key
revocation that I've cited here
um the main Insight in these in this
work in in this other work is to be able
to um
achieve Security in the presence of a
partial decryption article so it turns
out that these bb-84 State techniques
are not really robust to giving out
oracles that perform some sort of
partial or full decryptions whereas in
CCA encryption and obfuscation as you
can imagine you're trying to give some
partial decryption oracles out and so
here in order to do this we obtain we
use Subspace coset states which is a
more entangled version of uh you know
the bb84 state and is robust to these
types of decryption oracles
um so that's all I will say about that
um we also show in other work how to do
public publicly verifiable deletion
where the certificate of deletion can be
verified publicly and you don't need to
hold on to x's and thetas and things
like that in order to check deletion
um again I won't say too much about it
because I don't have
much time I'll just mention the results
um
we're able to build on the techniques
that I just showed you uh to prove a
gaussian collapsing conjecture that
first appeared in a work of parambo
um and from this uh one can okay in
public key encryption and fully
homomorphic encryption with publicly
checkable deletion from the learning
with errors uh or the asset and the sis
assumptions
um we can also show that injective
trapdoor functions plus X for a variety
of x's implies x with publicly
verifiable deletion again here I just
want to say that you know it maybe
sounds like this extra Assumption of
injector triangular functions is not
ideal so in in other follow-up work this
can actually be improved to one-way
functions or even one-way State
generators which yes
third probably is uh is is potentially
even weaker than one-way functions uh
it's a Quantum variation on one-way
functions and that plus X gives uh x
with publicly verifiable deletion
um and then I just want to mention that
similar results were obtained
concurrently and independently by
kitagawa nishimaki and yamakawa who also
showed that these assumptions are in
some sense minimal so this is the best
you can do for getting deletion for all
of these Primitives
um yep I think I'm already over time so
thanks so much for being here again
happy to take questions
what are you assuming in particular for
your obfuscation result
for the obfuscation result
distinguishability obfuscation and
one-way functions
thanks okay so um I'll take a break
thank you so much